Audrey thank you very much for that kind
introduction
um and thank you folks in the Hillsdale
College Community for inviting me and
for coming to listen to the to the talk
specifically I want to thank Doug
Jeffrey Marky rep Matt Dell and Kyle
Inman for their assistance uh in
preparing this talk preparing for this
talk
um Matt did an excellent job of
providing an overview with a problem and
I'm going to take a deeper dive in
um what I'm going to say doesn't require
any scientific background it's common
sense and caring about the welfare of
our country
but I want you to know that this talk
was presented to uh PhD candidates at
Harvard and MIT and it will be presented
in Grand rounds at a couple hospitals in
the next month so it is comprehensible
but it's not dumbed down
and I look forward to your questions
let me start my talk by saying
um I've had a little bit of a rough road
over the past few months six months or
so and that's why I'm delivering the
talk remotely I developed a serious
cardiac arrhythmia ventricular
tachycardia
um uh it started seven years ago and it
increased over the uh months of the
summer and the early fall
my journey has involved getting shot by
paramedics on my living room floor many
ambulance rides and many
hospitalizations
and in November uh it was critical and
I'm glad very grateful to be alive right
now
and the experience shows the good side
and the bad side of Medicine
uh on the good side I was fortunate
enough to have the complete attention of
two world-class doctors who spent six
hours one going on the inside of my
heart one coming through my chest wall
to the outside of my heart to
electrically map the aberrant signals in
my heart and to ablate them and so far
knock on wood
since November 18th I've not had a
problem
on the second day after the procedure I
was in still in the Intensive Care Unit
and cardiologists came by to round on me
and he he's an advocate of wider use of
cholesterol alluring Statin medications
than I am
so he started to cite the literature
about why I should be taking uh more
cholesterol lowering medicine than I was
and I asked him if he had read the
studies and of course he had and if he
understood that the end point of the
study that he was leaning on wasn't
really appropriate for the situation and
he said well he had and there was some
debate about that
he wouldn't back off and I asked him if
he was aware that when articles are
published in medical journals even the
most reputable medical journals and
they're peer reviewed and that's
supposed to
um assure that the articles are accurate
and represent the uh the findings of
clinical trials fairly I asked him if he
was aware that the peer reviewers
serving those medical journals don't
have access to the actual data from the
clinical trials and his advocacy of
Statin lowering drugs was based on
largely commercially all commercially
sponsored and largely commercially
influenced medical journal articles and
he somewhat meekly said yes he was aware
that peer reviewers didn't have access
to the data and I said well you know
that doctors trust that information
because it's so-called peer-reviewed he
said yes and I asked him I I this is a
surreal scene where I'm looking at the
cardiac monitor to see if as I'm getting
more emotionally involved in this
conversation if I'm starting to have
extra beats and getting into trouble and
I wasn't
um I asked him how he could present
himself as a learned intermediary
bringing Medical Science to the
education of Physicians and patients how
he could claim to to be alerted
intermediary without having actual
access to the data from the clinical
trials
for which he did not have an answer
so that will I'll get to that in my talk
but this gets to the heart of the
problem of the commercial takeover of
the medical knowledge that doctors
believe and Implement thinking that
they're providing the best possible care
to their patients but I want to remind
you that I'm here because of
advancements in medical science and
therein lies the problem we need medical
science it's it's a blessing to have
medical science but it's also it needs
to be in some way overseen because it
won't govern itself and with that I'd
like to start the talk
okay so conflicts of interest I think
they're important to let everybody know
what they are I'm the author of
sickening how big farmer broke American
Health Care and how we can repair it
and I recently served as a plaintiffs
expert in litigation involving the drug
company Celgene for the uh regarding the
drug thalamid and revlimid cancer drugs
okay here we go so the uh easiest way to
look at the health of a country and to
compare the health of a population with
other countries is to look at life
expectancy
this is a chart the blue line is the
average of 11 other wealthy countries
the green line is the United States and
what we're measuring here is life
expectancy at Birth from 1980 to 2021.
look back in 1980 1982 is when when I
went into Medical Practice the United
States was just about equal with the
other wealthy countries in terms of
longevity of Americans
and as the years have progressed you can
see that the green line has fallen
further and further behind the blue line
Americans well we were getting healthier
for sure living longer for sure but we
were losing ground to the citizens of
the other wealthy countries and then in
2019 in 2020 when covid came in uh our
death rate our longevity went down and
it went down again in 2021. the
difference between
the life expectancy in the other wealthy
countries and in the United States prior
to the coven uh uh pandemic so on 2019
data the difference is so great that 500
000 Americans die were dying before the
coveted pandemic 500 000 Americans were
dying each year in excess of the death
rates of the citizens of the other
wealthy countries five hundred thousand
sometimes when we see this data we think
well
um
it's not a good thing
but primarily the problem is that
um we have such a separation between
rich and poor in this country that it's
the poor people that have poor health
the wealthy people are still getting the
most advanced Medical Care in the world
and thriving
but that's not the case this really uh
very clever study looked at White
Citizens not because there's any racism
involved but to take out the possibility
of racism that white citizens in the one
and five percent highest income counties
in the country
have better health than poorer Americans
but have worse Health than the average
citizens in uh 12 other wealthy
countries
so it's not like wealthy folks we're
college educated who have insurance who
are employed
um it's not like they're getting the
best and the people the less fortunate
Americans are getting the worst we're
all suffering from this poor people
suffering more but wealthy people as
well
and for this
health
we are paying an enormous excess
the United States we average 12 914
dollars per person per year on Health
Care
and comparable the other comparable
wealthy countries listed here average
six thousand one hundred and twenty five
dollars now if you multiply that
difference the
6700 800 dollars if you multiply that by
334 million Americans
we're spending an excess 2.1 trillion
dollars a year on Health Care
we look at the uh spending that has been
the result of the uh Democratic uh
government the president and Democratic
uh legislatures uh with the um bills uh
the inflation reduction Act and the uh
covet bills and they added 1.55 trillion
dollars to the federal they will add
1.55 trillion dollars to the federal
deficit over a 10-year period
and Health Care is extracting 15 times
more than that in excess 12.1 2.1
trillion dollars a year and that's 21
trillion dollars over 10 years
so as Matt uh in his introduction of me
spoke about out of control spending
Eisenhower Eisenhower was referring to
the military industrial conflicts we now
have a medical industrial complex that
is sucking America's wealth away from
the other things that will make us
healthier and create Better Lives for
all Americans
foreign
tremendous disparity between the United
States and other wealthy countries what
ought to be the primary goal of our
health care and this is the best
definition I can come up with if any of
you can think of a better definition
let's talk about it when we get to
questions uh at the end of the lecture
but I think
as a general statement the primary goal
of American Health Care ought to be to
maintain and improve individual and
population Health most effectively and
efficiently
we're not doing that
so if that's the primary goal it raises
two critical questions why are we
failing so miserably on the achievement
of this goal and why are doctors and
other concerned
educated committed Health Care
Professionals willing to go along with
this dysfunctional system
and what I want to propose
is that one of the fundamental reasons
for the disparity between the health of
Americans and the health of people in
other wealthy countries is that this the
analogous analogous to the
military-industrial complex we have the
medical industrial complex and this
medical industrial complex has captured
what doctors and the public take for
medical knowledge I know that's a
radical statement and I will show you as
we go on uh how that evolved
we go back to 1981
excuse me
if we go back to 1981
this is an important time for me because
I was finishing my residency and
starting a two-year Robert Johnson
Fellowship where I learned my research
skills
and at the time the commercial intrusion
into our Medical Practice
wasn't an issue uh we as a fellow we
would spend hours dissecting the
articles in medical journals and never
did it uh was it an issue that there was
commercial bias but 1981 was a pivot
point Derek Bach was president of
Harvard University and in Harvard
Magazine from the spring of 1981 he said
that University's Reliance on industry
funding for research is causing quote an
uneasy sense that programs to exploit
technological development meaning make
money from technological development are
likely to confuse the University's
Central commitment to the pursuit of
knowledge
and why did he say that there were two
different
forces that were coming together grants
from the National Institutes of Health
and the National Science Foundation were
going down they've gone down through the
1970s and universities had to turn to
commercial sources to support their
research saying it was not only prudent
but it was essential for them to do that
so universities that had been
independent of commercial money and
could pursue knowledge for its social
and scientific value suddenly became the
uh were drawn into the marketplace and
they were producing knowledge for
commercial value not social value
this is a key quote here this article
from 1982 from the journal science
scientists who 10 years ago would have
snubbed their academic noses at
industrial money now eagerly seek it out
and you folks who are now at Hills
undergraduates at Hillsdale College
you've grown up in this environment
where it's
um normal for the professors and the
academics and the folks who teach
medical school to have commercial
relationships but it wasn't always that
way and I'm not sure it has to be that
way in the future